one of the things that you you talk
about that I found fascinating is that
the idea of democracy or the idea that
Authority should be answerable to the
people below actually comes from
barbarians that was really interesting
tell us about that well yeah the the
older traditional idea of of the West
often is told in a narrative that goes
back to ancient Greece and Rome as if
there was a sort of unbroken tradition
and it's very true that the West draws
on some ideas from ancient Greece and
from Rome it was a big influence but
there are problems historically with
that narrative there's really there's a
big break that happens and the West I
think really begins with the fall of
Rome it's what happens after the Empire
goes and then you get the barbarians the
Germanic tribes that come in and they're
really they're very poor they're
primitive but they have this enormous
focus on the individual and other sort
of individual pride and as a result a
sort of culture of not quite democracy
but of Freedom that of free men who sort
of vote together as who should be their
leader and that culture I think was
enormously important in forming the west
and giving it shape I mean not just on
its own I think also it's the
interaction of that with with
Christianity which is really the form in
which the traditions of Rome came into
that into that part of Europe because
Christianity and the church survived the
fall of Rome but I think that's a much
more honest place to start the
conversation about the west and also it
gets away from this sort of grand idea
of the West as something that's sort of
Roman and Imperial and gets back to the
real truth the the adventure of the West
is this poor primitive divided corner of
Europe that is nothing like as Rich
Nothing Like Us civilized in in
traditional terms as other parts of the
world like like China and the Islamic
world but that nonetheless has this
thing in it this spark out of which are
going to come things that have never
been seen before in human history things
like experimental science like
industrial capitalism like parliamentary
democracy there was something there
something there that's about the
individual and that that is partly I
think an inheritance out of those
Germanic tribes it's so interesting
because I've never really thought about
it like that but actually the story of
the West and the way that you describe
it is a story of depending how you want
to look at it either coming from very
humble beginnings or a tremendous
recovery from a gigantic setback which
is the collapse of Rome and then you
know I remember seeing
um various exhibitions here in the UK
about what happened after the Romans
left Britain and the tribes that came
after who hadn't directly been in
contact with the Roman civilization they
the gap between them and the Romans
technologically were so vast that they
thought that the buildings that the
Romans are directed here which were
nothing as impressive as the ones they
built actually in Rome
were the work of gods because they
couldn't imagine engineering at that
level and to come from that to being the
most successful civilization in the
history of the world is quite remarkable
isn't it it's quite remarkable and I
think the West you know it's the Triumph
of the smallest the Triumph of
giving power to individuals it didn't
really happen because of like a grand
Theory it happened because when Rome
fell and and then Europe was divided no
one could exert power from above to tell
people what to do plus you had this this
culture from below that was quite
individualistic anyway so then people
were free to to play around with ideas
there wasn't enough people who could who
could quash it traditional civilizations
which in many ways the West isn't are
much more about stability about power
from the top about great Empires and the
problem with that is you can get to
quite a high level of sophistication but
it's primary virtue is stability and
stasis and the people at the top keeping
power and they say no to the dangerous
crazy ideas that might take them forward
and so that's why you don't get
industrialization happening elsewhere
where you don't get all the crazy
inventions you know Columbus going to
the new world well so the Chinese had
great treasure Voyage is huge much more
sophisticated fleets that went out into
the world but they weren't that
interested because they thought they
were more important and it was all
controlled from the Imperial Court so in
the Imperial Court said well we don't
want to do that anymore and the ships
burn the ships whatever no one goes in
Europe you have an independent crazy guy
Columbus who's like I think that we can
get you know to to Asia by going over
the ocean and he was he was wrong that
you could do that because he thought the
world was much smaller than it actually
was and you know smart people could have
told him that but he had a crazy idea
and he he went around to different
monarchs in Europe and he said give me
some money I'll go I'll go and do this
some said no but there was always
someone else you could go to and in fact
I discovered which I didn't know that if
if the Spanish hadn't said yes Henry the
the seventh I think it was in in England
had said yes he said yes to Columbus's
brother but by the time he got back
they'd already gone with Spanish money
so it's an interesting counterfactual
you know that the English might have
been the finances of that Voyage but the
point was it couldn't be stopped there's
something Unstoppable in the west
because it's so divided and broken and
competitive there's always another Power
Center that you can go to that means
wild ideas sort of bubble up
foreign